yes sister this question concerns those
who work in the medical field yes the
nurses
doctors
um what happened to our
institution
our hospitals and so forth so they pay
because they have to work on sabbath
yeah they pay they pay
in many things we do sister we're just
like the world
in many now this is my church i'll die
for it you can't get me out of this
church except in the coffin
but i also know there are many things we
do that are simply influenced by the
world whether it's our hospitals our
schools our publishing houses and i just
sometimes you shake your head and you
realize the israelites were no different
they were god's people but crazy
and we are very much that way but don't
give up this is god's church
it is the object still of his supreme
regard i was an adventist bookstore once
and i have books by td jake and this but
i said what's the problem here
and you know this
come on
[Music]
are we here to make a difference or not
you go to hospitals you see a vending
machine with coke and sprite and you
know we have a health message
but we're still god's people
and god has to spank us sometimes to get
us straight so don't be discouraged
sister
we're still god's people pray do what
you can god will fix this church when he
does it will be painful